this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you for the introduction
Margaret and Gaurav and other people who
invited me here can you hear me in the
back Jerry Davis is reminding me earlier
the last time I was here and in this
room was 2005
and I lost my voice and I whispered my
way through the entire presentation
apparently I thought we hopefully that
won't happen today so it since 2005 I've
been at the University of Missouri and
it took me probably 10 years to figure
out how to talk to people about my
research I used to tell people I worked
on heterosis and hybrid vigor and
chimeras and all these kind of things
but I finally learned if I really wanted
to talk to people out in the public it
was the best thing I could do is say I
worked on the dogs of the plant world
because I could tell them that you know
you know a chihuahua and a Great Dane or
a dog but did you know their broccoli
cauliflower kale Brussels sprouts or one
species like a dog and then we can spend
the rest of the time talking about their
dogs and I'm just a nice professor
talking about Docs so that's that's
that's what I've that's first knowledge
bomb of the day for people let's talk
about your dogs okay now if I get on an
airplane and I don't want to talk to
people I just tell people I'm an
evolutionary biologist and that pretty
much stops the conversation class now I
put on my headphones and start reviewing
name scripts so but I if I am thinking
about evolution I really start with Oh
No 1970 and before that because oh no
postulated that gene duplication played
a major role in evolution and so in the
era of genomics I think the big update
to this is what I'm just going to tell
you is the thesis of my talk today and
that's that all duplications aren't
alike so if you spend a lot of time like
I do working with computer scientists
you really have to get them to recognize
the difference between tandem duplicates
and polyploid duplicates because they
behave differently and they operate
differently in terms of systems and so
you have to do this lesson building the
second thing which is going to be the
theme of my talk is these whole genome
duplications occur throughout most of
life taxonomically and also over time
and so I'm going to talk today about
both recent and ancient polyploidy and
now that we no longer rely on reference
genomes but use pan genomes to
understand variation this structural
variation
super important so if you're doing jiwa
you can't just do it on snips you have
to include structural variants if you
really want to understand the
genotype-phenotype map and that's just
not for plants and crops but also for
human diseases and things like cancer so
this crowd doesn't need to know about
what is polyploidy cuz you guys all know
what poly puddi is but i do want to make
the distinction between auto and a low
poly hoody so if your historical
cytogeneticist like a stamp eloquent you
define Auto and a law based on
chromosome pairing whereas I'm going to
talk about it today in terms of ancestry
and what I'm going to talk about
specifically today is a low poly puddi
where you have the merger of two
distinct species that come together so
another way the cid state this is I
really like chimeric thinks hybrids and
I'll even say grafting for Margaret's
sake so bringing two things together
that normally don't belong and how does
how do you get novelty from the
combinations of new things so I would
say the major advance since I started
grad school in 1994 and finished in 2000
was knowing that from sided genetic
evidence things like corn were probably
paleo polyploids from from compared to
sorghum based on even basic observations
but the biggest surprise hands down from
the rabid offices genome paper wasn't
all the things that were promised when
they started the rapid offices genome
project it was this figure and the other
analyses that showed that this tiny
little genome with bio chromosomes had
not one not two but three polypoid
events which were named alpha beta and
gamma from the most recent to the
ancient and at that time people
speculated that alpha was about the base
of the mustard family beta was at the
base of the eudicots and gamma was at
the base of all angiosperms and all
three of those assertions were law which
became the basis of the first part of my
talk as we sequenced grape and Ambro and
other things at least when I started as
a grad student we would say things like
Oh 70% of flowering plants are probably
played well that was based on that idea
of thinking about what a neo polypoid is
and Stowe mates and things like that but
if you now look deep in time about how
you define how Hoodie we now know that
all flowering plants extend flowering
plants including umbrella
have an ancestor that was polyploid so
we
really shouldn't ask ourselves are you
polyploid we should really say when was
the last time you were polyploid and so
us who are burger breads well the last
time we were polyploid was about 350
million years ago right so we're all we
are polypoid right and people like ethan
mix light had made a career studying how
those polypoid duplicates left from the
origin of poly puddi from vertebrates
are now part of our disease network and
of course there's a whole groups of
invertebrates that are polyploid as well
as the most species groups of
vertebrates like fish and frogs so if
you're in one of the four groups of the
school that works with crop plants and
you care about domestication you should
also know by now that crop plants are
compared to the wild plants more likely
to be polyploid okay so one question is
how do genomes and all the other omics
and networks evolve and brassicas or any
crop based on this knowledge so the very
important points i'm going to talk about
today are brassicas so the dogs of the
plant world I call old oratio cabbage
broccoli cauliflower so forth
rascal Rapa maybe you don't know is also
a dog or cat because it has all these
amazing Chinese vegetables to things
like turnip and Brassica napus is also
pretty burst has underground things like
rutabagas or Swedes leafy things like
siberian kales and then a whole suite of
whale seeds but here's the here's the
real big picture of what my labs been
doing so my lab along with I would say
Doug and Pam Soltis lab and maybe Jeff
Doyle's lab a few others have been
looking at how I played not from recent
times but also at the base of families
and all the way back to the origin of
flowering plants and so what I'm showing
here is Brassica if you imagine was
don't know what so imagine that in the
mustard family you had an eight
chromosome ancestor over evolutionary
time Arabidopsis became diploid eyes to
five chromosomes and then some one time
around 15 million years ago there was a
hex hexaploid e so to two rounds of
polyploidy a hexaploid event so you went
from 8 to 24 chromosomes in the
brassicas and then those deploys deploy
did not diploid eyes down to 9
chromosomes in Olesya 10 chromosomes in
Rapa 2 to 4 million years ago and then
those merged together to make Brassica
napus an alle polyploid
and so this is neil pali puddi Brassica
napus
mismo polyploidy this kind of where you
can see chromosome segments and blocks
they're acting like diploid x' but you
can still see these blocks and then
paleo polyploidy the alpha beta gamma
again and a rabid abscess where you just
have duplicate genes left but no sense
to me really among them so I'm gonna
give my talk today talking about these
three polyploid eras if you will going
from oldest to most recent oh by the way
if you add up all the polypoid events
together from the origin of flowering
plants arab adopts this is 12 x the
diploid brassicas or 36 X and Brassica
napus is 76 72 X so we publish that
genome and science and 2014 was the most
polyploidy genome at the time okay how's
the four parts of my junk okay so
yesterday day before stay way here so
Fei Wei and I and 200 other people over
the last decade have thrown ik together
a thousand some odd transcriptomes
under the leadership of I would say
mostly Jim Liebman smack and some other
people and we spend a lot of time on
this project
kind of like the rabid Offices Genome
Project to make a big tree a big nuclear
gene tree of flowering plants to
contrast to the mostly chloroplasts
organelle a tree and we also wanted to
look at gene family expansion but what
was the big result it's like they're
revved offices genome result with its
three poly put events the big results of
this paper has nothing to do with a tree
you really has to do with this 244
ancient WG DS whole genome duplications
across green plants 65 the match
published genomes every Lane plant
lineage has an ancient polypoid event
except for some weird ones liverworts
and by contrast almost none of the
things in the water algal we need just
have evidence of polyploidy dad in my
mind is the big word so now you don't
have to read the paper just came out two
days ago you can go with that okay now I
want to read you the last two sentences
three sentences so here is gene and
genome duplications have been considered
a source of evolutionary oddity
however the direct connections between
key innovations the specific gene
duplications are rarely known due in
part to lag times between duplications
and such innovations so earlier today I
met with gowrav and we're gonna say we
he is going to explain this because this
at the genes and everything else
duplicate yeah enzymes don't change
right away right it takes some time time
to do stuff so if you look on a tree
where polypoid events occur there's
always a lag between when they actually
get novelty and when they actually
specie 8 so anyway we'll be talking
about this in the future so and then
what do they say next in this paper with
a week we need to do more experiments on
this so in my mind the way you do these
experiments are not just in one system
but across the clay that has polyploidy
be it grasses and your polka knee or
brass casing okay so starting with the
oldest polypoid events this this part of
this project was motivated by what's the
origin of mustards so you know when you
eat wasabi or mustard or radish maybe
spicy things they don't have those
flavors and tastes because they're good
for us just because they're good for the
plants all right it's keeping the way
critters well they keep away a lot of
critters but it occurs like these
butterflies along got eat them and so
then what happens caterpillar shows up
nom-nom-nom-nom heats the plants and the
plant goes help and then here comes some
little wasp or something else so you
have these tri trophic interactions and
there's microbes involved in everything
so I have this really cool evolutionary
relationship which this relationship
alone is how Eric and Raven coined the
term coevolution was thinking about this
model so because I told you earlier
about Alpha Beta Gamma people didn't
know where this beta gamma event were
they thought that the one was at the
origin of you dicots another one beta
event I was in a meeting in China and my
clothing was there and he said something
he probably should have know which was
Oh Andy Pettis and I'm just looking at
by genome and it doesn't have beta and
so Pat edger that's true in my time
who's now a professor at Michigan State
said we're gonna find beta so that's
what this project started was we're
gonna find beta and then we're gonna see
an alpha these two ancient polypoid
events in rabid offices and we're gonna
see how they affect gooks and network
and then Pat defended his PhD in 2012
and we're going to publish the paper
just on the plant side and at that time
Chris wheat was driving across Missouri
to go to Kansas to talk about the the
Lepidoptera butterfly part of the story
and we lined up these trees and it was
too good to be true so we got to publish
this paper together
so then this is the only time in my life
for us that oh 50
anniversary at Peter Raven and polar
eggs paper blah blah blah it's got to be
a nature paper no no nature paper
science paper no no science paper so we
finally published in PNAS and it's been
our biggest by far things so NPR
Washington Post writer New Zealand Daily
Mail but I was still not too happy about
the nature science thing until it was
the opening joke of a Big Bang Theory
episode and then I said screw you
science in nature I got a job I don't
need your stupid journals anyway and I'm
not I'm gonna try to submit there
anymore and so up for the deal I will
tell a brief version of the story
because I feel that many times before so
what happens right plants evolve a novel
biochemical defense the plants radiate
we showed that insects evolved a counter
adaptation the cool part of this story
the butterflies don't have polyploidy
but they have a tandem gene duplicate
that gives them basically the
countermeasure to the mustard oil bomb
so then the the butterflies diversify
and then so forth and so on and now the
butterflies of course are cued into they
did what is necessarily defense the
other plant
okay so the big result of this is shown
in this figure so this is a first thing
we did was we made of the first nuclear
gene based phylogeny the Brassica leaves
before was unresolved so we could
actually do what hadn't been done before
which is map all the glucosinolates on a
tree to infer the order that they
evolved the second thing was we showed
with a probably put events were based on
transcriptomes and shadow genome so
there's the Blue Diamond for beta and
that blue diamond for alpha so we showed
where those probably played events were
the third thing was we compared where
the polypoid events were relative to
species radiations those are where the
stars are so the brass at KC and those
top ones in green the three big specie
host families are totally different than
all those other families if you're
taking pine systematics you probably
don't learn nted to plan Tracy and
plants estimate well maybe you do here
but most places know there's only one
species so then the other thing was the
innovation of guca simulate classes that
correspond to these polypoid events so
there's the where the radiations occur
and so we identified that there's these
novel pathways and similar work has been
done in a Cell an AC by Rob blast and
other people so since then this work has
continued so we've been updating the
kind of phylogenetic framework for
drastic Haley's thinking particularly
about glucose in
and we just posted it on bio archive a
paper that will expire in two other
polypoid events such as within the Clio
Maisie and some of these other families
and next slide we now have this really
large three three CSP is with GGI to
look at note that she not just the
genomes but also the transcriptome a
metabolic metabolic profiling across
members of this group and so we have
massive convergent evolution of various
metabolic pathways polypoid events we
have in nineteen twenty new genomes to
add to ones that already out there
there's this huge team including Jacob
Washburn in this room and others who've
helped with this and these recent
projects are we're going to go deep into
the Brassica oleracea crammed hispanica
philosophy Arvin C which he may knows
pennycress camelina and a rabbit and
Arabidopsis to look at to do like
platinum on genomes for about ten to
twenty s sessions and to do a whole
bunch of tissue specific profiling of
transcriptomes and metabolisms to see
how those change those networks and Jen
Weiss caber and Pat edger and ganglia
Stein and I are leading that effort okay
so that's ancient polyploidy in a
nutshell so old duplicates really matter
for big novel key innovations that can
result in classic and clay defining
features so what about these polypoid
events which you can't see in our
microscope but if you paint a genome you
would see like oh for every back sized
piece in a rabid abscess I three sty see
three of those Nebraska rabba or brass
Koehler Asya okay so here's here's a
simple slide showing the diversity of
Brassica Rapa you have things like
turnip
we should probably familiar with if
you're in any Asian market or a farmers
market that has Chinese vegetables you
have Chinese cabbage and bok choy you
have sarsens or oil seeds which come in
yellow and brown colors you have some
other field mustards and you have this
interesting thing or rapini
so you have a second so when we started
this study and this was a collaboration
with Mike Gore and Joe and Labatt
started with first MGBs sequencing of
the USDA collection what do we know
about Brassica Rapa well there were two
studies that were out one was in 2011
about how they're basically some
morphological groups there was a study
in
2014 which said actually there's
Geographic groups because things like
turnips are found in in Asia and in
Europe and so turnip like things are
more closely related things that are
looked different and then from then they
did together and then while we were in
the middle of our study there was a
large paper by Chang and Alan both rabba
and other Asia which gave out this tree
but as you can see it's the groups are
what we found but it's pretty comb-like
and how things are related and so what
we were when I was can we tell where
things domesticated multiple times where
they move by people and so forth and
then the real question that was burning
for me and also for some other students
was what about these leafy things are
they wild are they domesticated or are
they feral and so in this first study we
had a lot of a sessions 333 and we found
these major groups so we bought Joy's a
group on the top Chinese cabbage and
they weren't formed by hybrids which
some people had hypothesized we found
Asian turnips and various other Asian
vegetables in purple the sarsens
formed one cluster so yellow and brown
stars and are really just one thing
they're just different by a gene or two
and then we found these turnips at the
base and also some groups that are named
taxonomically like field west mustards
or polyphyletic now the problem with
this study so this we're the first ones
to show this but the problem in this
study is we didn't sample rapini and a
bunch of other types and also there
weren't really any wild samples that
were put in this so then in a follow-up
study this was a collaboration with Mike
marker and Gavin Conant and I on a plan
genome gram we looked at the diversity
of Brassica Rapa using transcriptomics
so our lab is one de Labs along with
Claude two pamphlets Jim Lehman's Mac
and others who really got off to us
early start using transcriptome was both
for phylogenetics and population
genetics so this was looking at 126
sessions we again found these same
groups as I talked about before but we
did answer one question which was the
rapini x' rapini x' here were clearly
fully nested next to be sarsens so
they're not at the base of the tree so
that was like a big result from this
paper in terms of how the topology of
these groups looked the
we didn't sample Asian turnips and a
bunch of other things the other thing
that we did in this paper
was this was the first time that a
demographic bonded like Daddy had been
used so some people who worked on those
and humans helped us work on these in
these plants and the two postdocs
working in on this project since riichi
and Mike Parker's lab and home on in my
lab both were into reading about where
cabbages and things are were in the
Chinese literature and so they're able
to track that oh where we saw the origin
of turnip was where the conform tablets
had them on in Babylon and Iraq and
where they were in classic poetry in
China at 26 years hundred years ago or
thirteen hundred years ago or nine
hundred sixty years ago pretty much
mashed and very rough since when these
demographic models put the spread of
Brassica Rapa mostly from east to west
so it turns out of course that that
follows the Silk Road pretty nicely and
there's lots of admixture back and forth
and in contrast there was a bottleneck
that's origin of the sarsens and that
happened about the same time as when
Alexander the Great went into that part
of India so that sounds like it's a very
nice and neat story except for this guy
so this is Alex McHale be he was a grad
student at evince rulers
I think Geoff was that one of your
students so this is Geoff Doyle's
academic grandson he's now a postdoc
here with sunny powers I think and he's
he came he's been collecting a ton of
these around the world
he says that's a really simple story
there's actually 13 different subspecies
of Brassica Rapa few folks are missing
there's all these feral things all over
the world and actually we his hypothesis
is that Brassica Rapa originated
probably in the caucuses and spread east
and west and so anyway there's a lot
more to do with this it's not a done
story at all all right so back to the
network idea so with this kind of
population in the genetic framework of
how abrasca rap has evolved what about
these duplicate genes and so Mike Barker
and the consortium of us have a
manuscript that we're putting together
where basically we're looking at targets
of selection with the particular
comparison between duplicates that come
by tain them versus polyploid and so
looking at the paleo logs for these we
ask this question do paleo logs have a
higher genetic diversity than other
genes of Brassica Rapa and the answer
this is
yes there's a four-fold higher diversity
of these paleo logs so now we although I
really like to do is take these lists of
paleo logs and look at them not just a
Nebraska rabbit but also in Brasco
Laurasia kales or an arugula or other
other plants that are related to this
event so I like to think about my I like
to ask people not just what their
five-year plan is but if you could
summarize your research into one
question what would it be
so this I don't have a one-word answer
but I have this picture so in my mind
I'm really interested in how networks
evolve over time and what happens when
you're a chimera so if you imagine any
network on the left side after a whole
genome duplication we have this plethora
of possibilities and over time you have
mostly GMOs but you can have novelty by
having new topologies of relationships
which is indicated by that arrow and red
and my thought partners in this over the
years have been Jim birch there Gavin
Conant Mike Freeling and others to think
about well if you wanted to understand
human medicine wouldn't be cool yet a
polyploid human right so if you want
understand a plant wouldn't be cool if
you had a polyploid plant oh my gosh we
had probably played plants so when you
double the system can you really look at
the constraints of network evolution and
what the consequences are for phenotype
crops synthetic biology and so Gavin and
Jim and I wrote a paper in 2014 on this
Jacob Washburn and Kevin Bird and Gavin
I wrote a paper in 2016 on convergence
and multiplies it's about convergence
and we published a paper in 2018 our
biology know makes and Network evolution
that is we spend a lot of time on and
then gal Rob and I on a Gugu best
published a paper recently on I'm
thinking about this in terms of
metabolism so if you want our
philosophical thoughts there they are
all right so back to experiments so this
is a unpublished experiment on Brassica
Rapa a rabbit offices and cleome and we
would have published it a long time ago
except the Brassica Rapa genome that we
used for it is still sitting and
published and a nun named groups
basement so I'll show you the results
and it will just repeat it someday so
the experiment was this was if you look
at a rabbit opposites abrasca across
tissues and across a bunch of different
challenging treatments over circadian
time course what do you see
so we using whites dark flooding salt
cold and methyl Jasmine aid so imagine
in a broad scheme you have whatever Arab
adopts this network that you want to put
together
Rask is gonna have three sub networks
from write the whole genome trip
locations X hexaploid E and over time
one of those sub genomes
LF these fraction unity still resembles
the ancestral Arabidopsis genome pretty
much where's the other two sub genomes
have have become highly fractionated so
if you look at the genome a Brassica
Rapa only seven percent of it is still
in triple kid thirty-two percent of it
is in duplicate and sixty-one percent of
it is single copy so now let's look at
some abiotic stresses only a fraction of
the duplicates are expressed in any
particular stress whether it's hypoxia
salt cold or methyl jasmine 8 but what
I'll show you is that they're different
duplicates in different situations so no
Rabbid OPS's if your entire interactome
is ten thousand eight hundred and eleven
nodes in a rabid OPS's this abiotic
stress node is about nine hundred sixty
one and in Brassica okay and then in
Rabbid offices by the way that stress
network two hundred thirty eight nodes
so 25% of those nodes go off and
everybody get stressed in Brassica you
have many more nodes from the sub
genomes 537 289 239 but only 2% only 2%
of those responds in all conditions so I
was explaining this to some non
scientist so I decided to make this
cartoon so I think but like this so
rabid OPS's is like one radar to detect
things and something goes wrong it sends
a firetruck every time brassicas got
radar sonar you know everything are and
it sends a firetruck a helicopter or a
boat depending on what kind of stresses
happen right so brassicas or anything
that has these kind of polyploid
networks have a lot more flexibility and
the kind of things that they can do in a
either a sub or neo functionalization
functionalized context let alone a
dosage context
okay so to dive further into this since
2013 we've made a pretty exhaustive
catalogue of concern non-coding
sequences among the brass a--casey so
I'm going to show a couple cartoons
where I have a gene that looks like this
where there's two green exons and a
bunch of little CMS's of these little
yellow boxes so after polyploidy this is
what you often see so on the top is an
Arabidopsis gene it's got 1 2 3 4 5 6
CNS is and it's got two exons if you
look in Brassica almost none of them
will look totally like that but you have
the one in the least fraction in the
genome will have all the exons and most
of those CMS's and then the two other
sub genomes we either have a loss or
have more CNS is lost so what is this so
Edie pay attention this is your slide so
CNS loss is consistent with sub
functionalization following gene
duplication so you can use polyploidy
and polyploid aware a I to think about
constraints in these kind of models so
whenever somebody comes and gives a talk
I got the latest and greatest CRISPR
high-throughput blah blah blah and I'm
gonna do all these mutants I'm like well
you go ahead I'm gonna spend two hours
on my computer and figure out that 90%
of those things you want to do or crap
because evolution has already done the
experiment so for me like when I look
like the pain and project or some of
these other projects we have going on
we're gonna model the most of the space
out right to know where we need to go
after for doing actual targeted gene
editing so use evolution okay was that
okay ad are we good alright alright so
now it's no it's just so I have this
data for like every gene that's in a
rabid OPS's that we know enough about so
here's just one cartoon example of
fractionation mutagenesis that you can
appreciate it so on the on the left is
in Arabidopsis gene on the right are the
three versions of it and brassicas so
let's go look at some cells and this is
just crude tissue stuff so of course you
can see where we're going with this with
single cell technology today so if you
put this gene under a couple of time
courses in a rabbit OPS's in the morning
it goes up and then in the evening that
goes down my typical gene that's
responsible i/o CNS six is light
responsive so you'll notice over here
what's going on
Brassica so so this is God its CNS thing
here's scene so this one's gonna respond
to light so sure not just Brassica
homolog of this response just like that
one
this one's dead we have to worry about
that what about this one oh it doesn't
respond to light so it doesn't do
anything right no of course it does
stuff so this rabid office is Jean it's
like the fire track right it shows up
all the time every tissue does
everything this this gene acts just like
Brassica all tissues all the time always
on this one Oh shows up in the dark
shows up when they're sweating right so
this is the boat this is the speedboat
version right okay and then there's
whole like exhaustive gene and the
network's bonus so you get the idea
okay so take-home point number tweetable
point number one who's tweeting Thank
You Margaret God one person F so
tweetable point number one you can now
use these systems to think about we used
to use terms like new at sub
functionalisation talk about a single
gene right I'll come of a single G
política gene now we can think about
networks of these ways care of yeah you
on board okay not sure all right
so in my fantasy experiment you have a
thousand and one perfect genomes of a
rabbit offices including tandem and ten
of duplicates and polypoid ghupat goods
you have your thousand one braska is you
have your thousand one sorghum's you
have your thousand one mazes and you can
tie all this together to really
understand constraints and Jeff what did
you call it today homeostasis why do we
have I mean maybe the real question
isn't why are things different but how
do they stay the same when they have all
these pretty levels on top of them and
go through meiosis and make pollen and
eggs okay so I've been thinking about
this a lot along with Gen Y scammer and
Gaurav and others about how could this
affect both primary metabolism things
like ham and c4 as well as specialized
metabolism Mike glucosinolates or
cardiac glycosides or name your favorite
metabolic network okay good olá ratio so
now we're on to the dog so this part is
completely
unpublished it's totally tweetable
because we've talked about before but
this is all new ok so this work is what
I'm going to present to you days mostly
been by my graduate student McKenzie
Mabry on the
left this is part of again a USDA grant
with Mike Gore and Joanne Labatt and
some other people but we also have Sarah
Turner on the right who's in now Jeff
Ross Sbarro's Lobby UC Davis so I'm
going to show you transcriptome data but
Sarah's got genome data and together
they have all this other morphology and
phenomics and Ino makes and stuffs I'm
not going to talk about so today I'm
just gonna talk about wolves and dogs
okay so I love this new trend for deep
domestication because every time people
write a review paper let's start with
sack laments tomato they put in the
review paper this picture so I'm like if
I don't write the d domestication grant
for Brassica like the next month i'm a
fool right so but there's a problem with
this picture one it doesn't show how
those different things are related and
two that thing in the middle is fiction
there is no wild mustard plant that
looks like an annual herbaceous thing
that's a Chinese white kale that's a
domesticated thing so first of all what
the heck is that that we're gonna be
domesticated doesn't look anything like
that okay so who are the wolves and who
are the dogs so these are all the other
things by the way besides the kind of
five canonical cabbage broccoli Cockrell
you have as I learned yesterday they
were part of my trip so far Margaret and
Griff his grip here could God
so anyway grip hi we would all looked at
all these amazing there's like more
diversity in this field of kills and
I've seen in my whole lifetime it's so
there's all these different kales and
collards and walking-sticks like
phenomenal diversity like who cares
about dogs these are way cooler than
dogs okay so what's the progenitor
alright so here's some possible
progenitors
so unlike Brassica Rapa which occurs on
the continent raska relatives wild
relatives in sea genome which also have
9 chromosomes are mostly in the coastal
Mediterranean so they got these like
kind of really hard leaves they go like
looks like they're like can take salt
spray they're witty
at their base their perennial and these
are all the possible contenders for who
could be the extant closest relative to
Brasco relatio okay so there's been
three competing hypotheses out there so
if you're British
you like hypothesis the organism Britain
said of surprise no and so why would you
think that well if you go to the coast
of UK you find things that look like
wild cabbage
they're also on the coast of France and
Spain but
British don't care about that so you
think okay well British Wow cabbage
what's another so if you like the babble
of arguments which snob is also false
but like if you like the argument where
there's the most number of species that
should be the origin so the most number
of wild sea relatives are in southern
Italy Shaklee Sicily and Sardinia and
Corsica and then recently people have
done phylogenetic work not on DNA but on
the words so if you do phylogenetic
analysis of the words of the species
Brassica Kritika which is on Crete
Nebraska Haryana switch is in Turkey and
neighboring area would be the progenitor
sorry not presenting wrong term the
extend sister species to domesticate by
scores so those are current three
hypothesis so let's see what we find
so we started this project and again
this really nice paper check it out came
out that shows this relationship where
you have cabbages kales Brussels sprouts
cobby's as one group cauliflower
broccoli call you know there's another
group and then Chinese kale sister the
rest of those but not really a good
analysis of what was sister to it as far
as the wild things go okay so I have two
questions I want to post here first
how are the wild relatives related to
each other and to boscola racy and where
they occur so who's the wolf and then
how are all these dogs related to each
other okay so this is i'm only going to
talk about i'm going to show you kind of
popjam phylogenetic trees today but
here's the data that we collected we've
done this for rapa old erasing apis and
some other things like arugula we grow
plants in a growth chamber we put them
in four replicates we have all these
leaves we have kind of a semi - but way
called undergrads who harvest these
things and do the little vials and so
you know leaf four is for RNA leaf 2 3 &
4 is Leafs can leave to s 4 metabolomics
leaf 3 is for ayan omics and we have all
this data one undergrad brandon guidance
Kalka really got in a raspberry pie and
so he made these like raspberry pi
system for looking at it so we published
a little paper on this like this is like
a pretty thing so you wonder how you get
a high 50 papers you have a good
question like NZ mentoring undergrads
publish little papers like this along
the way about a method like raspberry pi
by totally cool undergrad project
okay so now some results so here's the
first PC I don't think my core is
seamless yet but anyway the first PCA
here is on the on the right are wild on
the left or all the domesticates and so
who are these guys here that are the
wild ones that are closest to
domesticates okay they are
Brassica Kritika and Braska ancona okay
so let's look at apologies so this is
the pretty typical these days in Philo
genomics if you look at this tree it has
100% bootstraps and you can run a
different program and also have
hundred-percent bootstraps it'll be a
different tree alright so bootstrap
values are kind of meaningless in this
era when you have 100% bootstrap for
conflicting relationships so that
there's a whole other conversation have
about that okay so what we find a
monophyletic group of domesticates
Brassica Kritika sister to those
Brassica and kana those and then some
alternative topologies they flip or
they're both sister to the domesticates
that's and here's the other thing so
sorry my friends in the UK but your wild
cabbage on the coast is not wild it's
not a wolf it's a feral dog but it's a
feral dog okay so that's what she got
there and then within the domesticated
plants the domesticated brass keys you
got collard greens and cabbages and then
kuraby cauliflower broccolis and we got
lots more to do in this so I told you
that I told you that's okay so where we
go in the future so we have all this
other data to use not just for G wasps
and T wasps but we have all these
glucosinolates and things to work on we
have morphometrics and leaf scans to
play with and we may also work with Dan
xie wood or some other folks on this and
then finally the reason why I came here
was to go out yesterday and look at the
huge diversity set so we have this
amazing G wasp platform it would be so
easy to add some of these other things
that some of the students here have been
working on for Brassica and that would
be fun to do together and also for
machine learning from other thing from
phenotypes to enzymes like there's a lot
of things that would be fun to play with
with people here elsewhere and my last
little piece on this is on fertilization
so I like to think of polyploid polypoid
is and when doing a genome evolution but
I've been thinking about these little
feral dogs as ways to think about
investigation because it's like
domestication reverse so if we have
these witty cabbages off the coast of UK
France and Spain well guess what
they're also off the coast of California
so when I was undergrad at Berkeley in
1986 Herbert Baker would talk about
these wild cabbages that are now off the
coast of California and that of D right
they've like they become woody again
right and so like this is like a huge
project just sitting here to look at the
parallel d domestication back to
wittiness and preemie ality across these
different habitats well and by the way
if you go to the islands of no Canary
Islands or Channel Islands and off the
UK and Europe you get walking sticks
these are 8 foot tall woody
like so if I was if there's still money
for a rabbit obvious biofuel money this
would be the thing you'd want to work on
but that money is not here anymore so
that's too bad damn ok so how can we use
this d domestication paralyzation
process to understand crops in a rapidly
changing environment
okay so last part how am i doing on time
how much time do I get oh good okay so
last part so this is normally I do this
thing switch they do the neo poly points
and in with the base so this word this
time I did it backwards experiment so so
now I'm going to talk about what happens
right after you make a poly so Brassica
napus is classic heterosis right so on
the left is a Brassica oleracea rapid
cycling plant it's about this tall
flowers and 30 days or so on the right
is Brassica Rapa
fast plan right Wisconsin fast plain
flour super fast in the middle as
Brassica napus
are was it I think bushel has mini maize
to the subversion mini maize so but it
blasts cannabis things like this tall
you know commercial canola is like this
all right this thing is like this but I
can we can do when we first made them we
can do two of these a year so the origin
of this experiment I don't know if you
remember but you know learn Reece bird
became famous for making three hybrid
sunflowers three maybe five and
comparing them to natural sunflower and
showing that evolution repeated itself
when you replay the evolutionary tape
for chromosome rearrangements in
SunPower so Tom Osborn where this star
project started in Wisconsin and
agronomy saw that experiment he's like
three five like let's do a hundred
so we made a hundred resynthesize
Brassica napus lines but this is not in
the area of next-gen sequencing this is
the era of RFLPs and I could put 50 on a
southern blot so that's like there's 50
or not a hundred in this study so over
time what happened is this is just a
portrait of one of the lines myself
themself themself them in like by
generation one two three four five so
this one became to work right other ones
became early flowering other ones became
way flowering so even though they start
off with the same exact homozygous
parents double haploid we got this huge
change in phenotype so how could that
happen
man almost like his parents so we
discovered some stuff and I'll show you
so that big experiment was actually
first thought of from one cross so in
1995 coming song and Tom Osborne
published a paper where they made some
crosses now they weren't self plants and
they were so but they showed dynamic
changes and a lot of people didn't
believe them a lot of people didn't
believe that result so this was a more
careful experiment where they had inbred
lines of Rapinoe Laurasia and this is uh
so Jeff was Eric Ron's your undergrad
yes so Eric Tron's who was an undergrad
here at Cornell in Jeff's lab came to
Wisconsin I think I should want to work
with Ken Sytsma but ended up in Tom
Osborne's lab doing Brassica stuff so
this is what Eric did sorry and the
other nice thing is right down the
hallway is Ricky I'm a senior's lab
which is like a famous lab for working
on flowering time network in Rabbid
offices so eric had the smart idea to
glue what a massino's lab was doing in
rabbit ops LC and konstanz with always
going a Brassica because there'd be
three copies right of these flowering
time genes so eric started to do this
experiment we made these crosses and
selected for early and late flowering
and after six generations of selfing
they're basically two species if you
throw the seeds out the early flowering
ones whenever seed the late flowering
ones so had that happened so fast oh and
by the way this was about the time when
hopi huckster and other people were
making a lot of hay about speciation
genes so everybody wanted to find the
speciation gene so we didn't find a
speciation gene so then we did this big
experiment we made 50 lines that were
started so 50 independent lines it's not
one line there's 50 independent lines
and we sell them and we published the
big paper and this was in 2007 and we
followed up in 2011 and I'll show you
some new stuff next but when you first
made them they're all identical but
after
even five generations of cell fame they
were really diverged both genetically
epigenetically and phenotypically so
here's I I think this is the only slide
I also showed in 2005 but I always show
it again and again so this is my most
important slide and you have to learn
how to spell homie ologists after this
okay so these are rearranged macaws by
homie Allah guests recombination so you
know in a diploid so in green is
Brassica Rapa diploid ellos breast glory
circle they have homologous 100
chromosome exchange and aloe polypoid
they have homie all that gets you had
two bowels not one Val two vowels homie
Allah Gaston exchanges so if you ever
get that reviewer comment how to spell
ho Malik has changed that was me or Jim
burglar so as a result of homologous
chromosome exchanges you can have so
okay so these changes are reciprocal
right the exchanges are reciprocal but
as a result of a punnett square you can
have non reciprocal inheritance okay so
you can get results that look like this
you can also get reciprocal exchanges
okay so these rearrangements can have
huge effect on dosage and we called them
speciation rearrangements time so
imagine that these bubbles are phenotype
so let's say F LC and konstanz are here
Brassica Rapa and the big circles
flowers and say 10 days Brassica
oleracea and a little circles flowers
and say 30 days and the mid parent
flowering time for napus is 20 days you
have a chromosome rearrangement on the
one on the top and the one on the bottom
you have the two separate flowering
times right and you can do that for any
pathway right whether it's firing time
or glucosinolates or whatever so does
this happen a lot so we published this
result and again just like the 95 papers
list so we don't believe it oh now we
believe it but it's only true in your
recent besides lines never happens in
nature so then we think was the genome
and in the genome we found 17 17 homie
all August exchanges and then people
said okay well that's fine only occurs
in recent the size Brassica you're crazy
crop brass can use but doesn't happen
any other crop well then after we
published this paper was found in weeds
and then strawberry and then track your
pogon then bunch of grasses so if you
don't know about homologous exchanges
and you're doing pan genome work across
any group of plants you should really
think about this is a source of
variation if you're now looking at copy
number
or presence/absence various should you
care if you're a plant breeder this
sounds pretty obscure to me I don't know
who cares about these ChromeOS okay so
here is the picture of the homologous
exchanges across winter canola
darm or Bristol spring canola it be so
some Japanese and Korean types synthetic
type the kale one that I'll show you
next
kale type napus in a sweet rutabaga all
those color boxes are homologous
exchanges I just highlight one in green
that's glucosinolates so good suddenly
evolution totally partly at least
responsible for by these homologous
regions and then we also see these for
all kinds of other things
and now another crops so this this this
these 50 lines haven't died so we're
still replaying the evolutionary tape so
this paper was post on a bio archive I
think two days ago it's actually called
replaying the evolutionary tape to
investigate sub genome dominance now a
Brassica napus
so Kevin Burge hadn't either hooth Melea
gihan bunch of a bunch of other people
led by um pat edger and rob and urine
they looked at deeply at 6 of these 50
lines and they looked at methylation
bias homologous expression and what are
they finding guess what repeated
patterns so it really matters everything
about constraints what happens who are
the parents who's the mom who's the dad
and you'll see the same things happening
over and over again so again you don't
have to CRISPR out everything you can
learn something from evolution so ok
Margaret B my Twitter person okay here's
Twitter point number 2 so you can find
by making synthetic a low poly poids you
can see things happen faster like
homologous exchanges so you will believe
them because you see them faster and
over and over again you don't think it's
an experimental error you're just think
oh my god homie Alex exchanges actually
happened they're not gene conversion
events they're homologous exchanges you
need you there no and then you don't see
them as being weird you've seen them as
something that are real and then
suddenly you could see them not just
Nebraska but be peanut and whole bunch
of other things now ok so what about the
history of Brassica so Brassica napus of
course is known a part of the triangle
view originated from the combination of
Brassica Rapa the AAA genome and brass
collar Asya the CC genome so
long-standing questions which of these
vegetables are the parents
and then once you get Brassica napus you
have further diversification into
oleifera which is a rapeseed types
subspecies were pepper which is really
bigger speed Swede and fabulo a which is
Siberian kale so if you think about
multiple origins are these different are
these different warfare types different
multiple origins or do they diversify
from the same thing and then finally you
have big differences in both winter and
spring types so when we started this
project we had reference genomes for
Brassica Rapa Brassica oleracea brass
cannabis and we did a massive
transcriptome and now resequencing study
but I'm just going to show you the
transcriptome stuff today and so the big
question for this and this is a study
led by home on he came to my lab from
Wuhan as a visiting PhD student and his
now stayed on was a postdoc and this
paper was just published recently in
Nature communication his big question
for his PhD project was is it true that
there's multiple origins of Brassica
napus because that's what's in the
literature and if it's true
how do multiple versions happen do the
rutabagas wheat types evolved from
things like turnip and kohlrabi do the
leafy siberian kales evolve from things
like the leafy brassicas and of the oil
seeds of all things like the sarsens or
were there multiple origins to one thing
like an oil seed type and then they
diversified or was there a single origin
so this was this is the three options
for what he was pursuing okay and so we
got a global collection of Brassica
napus and unlike a lot of other studies
we include a rutabaga and siberian kale
we did like some really nice generated a
lot of really nice RNA cka NGSS data and
here's the for those of you are
interested methodology here's the
methodological take-home at this point
it really mattered whether you used a
reference genome a single reference
genome or whether you used a pan
transcriptome or pan genome the
groupings weren't differed in structure
but the pile of genetic trees were
really different so if you're thinking
about that that would be what I think is
the big take home with this paper and so
there's home and this is the paper that
I'm going to be talking about for the
next few slides that just came out okay
so the first big result was we
discovered a new group of Brassica napus
so we have the typical rapeseed types in
Europe and North America and in Asia and
then you have spring types and then you
have Siberian kales and you have
rutabagas and then there's this
interesting little group I'll come back
to later
intro s right here okay now if you make
it free so this is where it gets wonky
so we always get these four monophyletic
groups so rutabagas Siberian kale winter
rapeseed in East Asia and spring
rapeseed are always one group every time
you look no matter hey look these other
winter rape seeds that occur in Europe
and America and Asia are a paraphyletic
mess at the base of this and then the
relationships among that paraphyletic
mess and all those form on top for the
groups really vary depending on what
methods you use to make this kind of do
this kind of tree building exercises and
there's also Network versions of this
but I'm just sharing the cartoon version
of it today okay so I've been thinking
about you know we started with this
Brassica napus who's your mother you
know so there's a baby bird that runs
around asking all the other animals
about who's your mother we still don't
know who the mother is
because I don't think we have the right
diploid extant relatives but then my
Chinese postdoc says we know that that
story isn't a really original story and
China we have the story except it's a
tadpole so he showed me these stamps
where the tadpole runs around and asked
the fish in the crab and who's your
mother so I didn't realize this is one
of those cross-cultural stories are you
my mother so we haven't figured this out
for neighbors either
all right so just to finish up this this
with this paper had in it so we found
these six Brassica napus groups there's
a ton of admixture across them
particularly that will seed varieties we
can't confirm what the general tale is
that multiple origins happen it seems
that section more like back crossing the
nuclear organelle or for lodgings
actually showed that that intro s group
that we discovered is when you sow in
China they used to grow Brassica Rapa
for the oil seeds and after World War 2
they grew Brassica napus but they back
crossed it to Brassica Rapa for disease
resistance and other things so that's
what that group is is just the
introgression YZ group that's got these
other ones in it and then I didn't talk
about it today but basically you looked
really hard for all the selective sweeps
we found focusing on rutabagas and
Siberian kales because everybody else is
looking up oil seeds we have a lot of
fighter hormones to chase down and other
kind of metabolic things to go after and
just like with Brassica Rapa nuis
there's this obvious sub genome both
physical asymmetry and expression
asymmetry and healthy
show themselves and so where we're going
with next on this is I think Mike Gore
and John McCain a bunch of people have
pan genomes a bunch of the canola types
we're making pan genomes of rutabaga and
Siberian kale hopefully someday we'll
bring all these together and have a big
party and then of course we're Chris
bring out every else is doing oil seeds
and glucose amides we're actually going
after some other targets that nobody
else cares about so the future so here's
my future this is my ed buck ed this is
your slide number two for you and
friends so from a sub genome assignments
are problematic if they're just sorghum
and maize comparisons you need other
genomes to fill in who the parents are
to do it right it still biased
fractionation but it's going to be
definitely so in general as a good
system a distant file geneticist move
away from pairwise comparisons to pilo
genomic comparisons that's message
number one no matter what your omics and
then think about the modeling so how
would you model you know what
deleterious alleles you want to go after
using the framework of both Philo
genomics and population genetics so we
spelled this out and a 20-18 paper and
err yes and then we've had a couple of
some other thought pieces about this
both with gal rob and aj b Sarah turned
her song and Jeff Rossen a bar and I
talked about these evolutionary insights
impacting plant breeding so what reading
5.0 I don't know what we would call that
and then and this is an older paper but
I should be read it on the plane out
here Jacob Washburn and some of us wrote
this paper on convergent evolution and I
think that there are some nice ideas and
they're about thinking about constraints
so I will just end by acknowledging my
funding sources including USDA which is
new for me because I have friends here
National Geographic is new so now I get
up have music or so that I don't know
what that means exactly for National
Geographic and I and I didn't talk about
today but we have a small D we do II
grant do you t I'm using brassicas a
low-dose radiation sensor which actually
can just plug in with all the other
stuff that we got going on and JG is
giving us a ton data and I didn't talk
about an orchid mycorrhizal fungi
project today and so these are the
people that do the work so I talked
mostly about the work done by Mackenzie
Oman and these are new students who are
working on various projects that have to
do that follow-up mostly CRISPR and
functional genomics and I have had this
great visiting scientist
why don't you shun from China this year
has been helping us with double haploids
and CRISPR also and the what I'm most
proud of our lab these are undergrads
because they come in as whatever
pre-meds or not knowing anything really
and they end up going to grad school
grad school over the all over the world
doing cool stuff so thank you fun last
fun fact we didn't know it
pumpkins were really good really cool
for people because like they used to
carve turnips and rutabaga and it was
really hard you got your hands doll
bloody so our lab is an annual turnip
carving party rutabaga party this last
year we'll do step back this here but
home much prefers to park our pumpkins
down into these so all right so that's
it thank you questions I can handle it
awesome all clear clear as mud alright
go
so the modern that was the guy sending
out all images for stress but is it that
it's just that team is on the way
personalization and it just regains of
the activities that were there before by
chance I start it's not selected
response public instead it so yeah so
this is Gavin carnival here you would
love your question so we actually wrote
a paper about noise we Swiney in the
progeny so you have to distinguish noise
which I would saw things on the way the
solution ization versus things that are
fixed by sub-conscience ation right if
yeah it's true original for son when to
stop vocalization there's you're stuck
with them or you can't get rid of them
but if it's these things that it's kind
of noisy and they're on their way out
again like you're still playing so this
is why I like your work on enzymes
because okay so in poly play was
everyone to do they once he probably put
it on the tree and they want a map that
where that probably put even
you have diversification no yep Olli
play well and evolutions got to tinker
around and pick out how the young signs
are gonna find their substrates or
figure out how they're gonna do their
homeostasis game oh boy and then you get
a novel trait and then they can
diversify right so what's the time lag
for that so for me thinking about AI or
or whatever what's the time frame that I
want to look at after polyploidy like so
how far is it like is the if I'm what
path when you're looking at do I want to
look at the music polypoid events the
alpha-beta events or the Brassica napus
event so I don't know what your enzyme
you're working on or whatever but for me
that's like where I would start with
answering a question or whether it's
cardiac glycosides or but most of these
I think are fixed if they're like have
really deep partitioning between tissues
and and so the thing we've been trying
to model is to gen-y skateboard I have
been thinking about well if I really
wouldn't about the glucosinolate module
how do i spread my the dollars between
different species sessions within a
species and tissues and time points
right and so like okay well let's think
about that yeah if you have somebody
prior idea about how big the module is
you can figure that out right or what
the gold standard stress is it's going
to do five things instead of one thing
copper sulfate instead of methyl just
maybe or I don't know I'm making that
but anyway so some of these are noisy
right but that's when we look at a pot
so I showed you a canonical example but
in a pop gym framework and maybe some
other things like they don't look as
clean as that oh maybe this pseudogene
izing and that Rab adopts this cold wine
but not in a RAB job just layer or I
don't know if that answers your question
but we're just looking at a snapshot by
which is why you need to test notes so
trend towards woodenness you get so you
can think about the things that cause
the domestication by what exactly
constraint begin so do you think the
witness was on islands where you see
plants growing anyway so is there any
are there any insights that are jumping
out from that that you hadn't maybe some
of that that are providing an idea of
what that canalization process is and
why you don't see
such overwhelming diversity of forms
given the overwhelming genetic potential
and variation that's out there version
of the question for people on Zoo
soar is it
do we see canalization yeah so so the
question is do we see any patterns of
the domestication that may tell us about
some central process yes okay we don't
know yet we're just starting so for me
though again it's like what's the scale
the problem are we trying to figure out
okay and Brassica how does Brassica
become woody or do we want to look at
like well how do all frog plants become
woody and look at s Tracy also and some
other ones right and so there's a
project in in Europe where people are
looking at wittiness while baying both
naturally on islands mostly these kind
of T domesticated types so I'm curious
things you're sure so just to narrow the
question a little bit so things that
share the same hexaploid e in the purse
to see what's the difference between
things that were perennial that then
became more woody versus things that
were domesticated in Deraa basis and now
become woody kind of what can I learn
about wood enos from the difference
between those two right and are there
constraints are they as always the same
little switch is similar transcriptional
factors over and over again so that's
the question I don't know the answer any
other questions I can't answer one more
question than we got to go so you know
the helicopter in Nice is that okay yeah
clearly it didn't go that same route
right so what you thought about this or
the negative asked
so maintaining some of those options
maintaining extra copies of jeans
well there's clear I mean you mostly
have gene loss to drift and clearly I
mean we all know that genome size is a
huge cost right I mean rabid office
entire lifecycle occurs in the time span
that lilium does meiosis so you know if
I had to choose Oh vast and weedy yeah
but but I just think trying to broaden
your question or thinking about
constraint there's different ways to
have variation too right so like spice
variants or you know transposon all blah
so I'm just focusing on my own research
program it's just trying to focus on
tandem versus probably play duplicates
but there's a lot of ways that variation
could happen and certainly there's
genomic so when I think of genomic
architecture that's what I'm thinking of
is it's kind of network architecture and
so what did a rabid offices give up by
giving up those other networks right I
don't know
doesn't have but doesn't have a
helicopter but has a pretty fast speed
you know it has a pretty fast boat right
so can I poorly answer another question
I've done two I'm two for two on zero or
it's time to go time to go sorry this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu